[Music]
so the past 80 years if you want to know
what people want why they do the things
they do what they're going to do you ask
them in a survey but people may lie to
surveys but it's been shown that people
are really really honest on certain
internet sources particularly their
Google searches so they tell Google
things they might not tell to anybody
else they might not tell family members
friends surveys even themselves
sometimes and by mining this data we can
get better insights into who we are all
the data analyzes anonymous and
aggregate but you can see patterns in
this so for example before an election
if you ask people in a survey are you
going to a vote pretty much everybody
says yes our huge percentage of people
say yes even if they have absolutely no
intention to vote just because it makes
them feel good to tell a survey that
they're voting but you can actually see
based on where searches for how to vote
or where to vote are highest how high
turnout really will be in different
parts of the country and that's a very
accurate predictor of who's actually
going to vote when I started this
research I measured how frequently
people made racist searches in the
United States and the searches I looked
at were very very striking
strikingly racist searches looking for
basically jokes
mocking African Americans and I was
struck by how frequently people are
making these searches in the time period
I was looking at it was as frequent as
searches for Lakers and migraine and
Daily Show
so not a fringe search and I was also
shocked by where these searches were
located if you had asked me where's
racism highest in the United States
before I saw this google data I would
have said the south if you think of our
country's history of slavery the Civil
War we usually think of racism as a
southern issue but among the places with
the highest racist search volumes
include western Pennsylvania Eastern
Ohio upstate New York industrial
Michigan the real divided racism these
days is not North versus
South its East versus West where you get
a lot less of this west of the
Mississippi River as compared to east of
the Mississippi River yeah and then if
you remember the 2008 election all the
way back then when Barack Obama was
elected president after the election
there was this question did people care
that he was black and they asked Gallup
as people and some other surveys asked
people and 98 99 % of Americans said no
no no of course not this was not a
factor in our voting decision but you
actually see very very clearly in the
data that Obama did far worse than other
previous Democratic candidates in places
with higher races search volumes and
this isn't explained by anything else in
the data it's not explained by
demographics or gun ownership or church
attendance or liberalism the main factor
that predicts where Obama did worse than
other Democrats is how frequently they
made racist searches on Google
anyway this this data kind of languished
I think on my website for a while but
then during the 2016 Republican primary
some data journalists got data on where
Trump was doing best in the Republican
primary Trump of course was saying some
very very racially charged things and
people were expecting that these were
gaps that he would collapse because
because he was saying things they're not
supposed to say you know retweeting
false statistics about how frequently
African Americans commit crimes or not
repudiating support from a leap former
leader of the KKK saying that black
lives matters protesters should be
roughed up and then what the data
journalist found is the single highest
predictor of where Trump was doing well
was the measure of racist searches on
Google so the same hidden racism that
was heard secretly hurting Obama was
waiting for a candidate to support and
helped Trump tremendously in the
Republican primary so in the 2016
election one thing that was very very
clear in the data is that African
American turnout was going to be way
down because if you looked at cities
with 90% black populations or 95% black
populations searches for information on
voting were way lower than the previous
two elections so this was a clue that
Trump may do better than expected
because he wasn't going to get because
Clinton wasn't going to get the same
black support that Obama had gotten and
I think as far as predicting the
elections just based on searches we're
not really there yet because we haven't
had enough elections to test the models
on you only have a few we've only had a
few elections to build to build the
models and where it's poles have been
building models over many many elections
I think there definitely are clues in
searches for which way people will go
they're a little more subtle than we
usually think so for example you can't
predict which way a state's going to go
based on how frequently they search for
a candidate it's not like places that
search for Trump more go for Trump in
places that search for Clinton more go
for Clinton the problem and can probably
guess it's obvious is that you might
search Trump because you love him or you
might search Trump because you hate him
so it doesn't really tell us too much
there are some subtle indicators that
seem to have predictive powers one that
I've found is the order in which people
search candidates about 26% of searches
for Clinton in the previous election
cycle also included the word Trump so
people search for Clinton Trump polls or
Trump Clinton debate and it turns out
interestingly there's a subtle clue in
which way people will go based on the
order in which they list the candidates
in their search so if people search
Trump Clinton polls they're much more
likely to go Trump if people search
Clinton Trump polls they're much more
likely to go Clinton but it's going to
take a lot of Elections to kind of build
these models and weight these models and
figure out exactly how to translate the
searches to vote totals but I think
there is some information in these
searches for the purposes of predicting
elections
[Music]